[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 177 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Michelle and I'm here with my
colleague Mark merchandani hi mark
hi Michele how are you today I'm doing
well how about you I'm doing very very
good and I'd like to take this chance to
call out that May which is the month
that we're currently in is mental health
awareness month mental health awareness
month what exactly does that mean so I
have a vague idea of what it means and
through some readings and you know a lot
of tweet conversations and people just
kind of promoting this idea of it hey
it's important to take some time and
recognize that sometimes you need to
take a step back sometimes you need to
take some time for yourself I think
there's a lot of negative stereotypes
about like going to therapy and there's
a lot of ideas out there you know people
shouldn't talk about them more and I
think it's important to raise awareness
of it and that's why I think that having
a month dedicated to helping people
understand what mental health awareness
is and why it's so important for people
to kind of focus in on not overloading
themselves with work taking time for
themselves so I think of an environment
where they feel good all of these kind
of things are really important to focus
on and so that's why it's kind of cool
that there's a month dedicated to it
yeah so I really like the fact that we
are talking about it that we're sort of
normalizing it and making it clear that
there's no shame in it it's a way of
taking care of ourselves in the same way
we take care of our physical health one
of the best phrasing for this is from a
book by Brene brown one of my favorite
authors so she describes it as if we are
exhaling all the time we need to be
inhaling and mental health awareness
month is a time for us to inhale so that
we can exhale well very interesting I'm
gonna have to check that book out it was
a good one I believe that one was from
braving the wilderness which was one of
the most recent ones that I read
gotcha maybe we'll put a link down in
the show notes great idea perfect well
on to the main content today we have a
very very very very very list at six
very seven very cool interview with well
why don't you introduce him that was a
lot of varies so I agree that it was a
fascinating interview with our friend
John Bohannon so he Co presented a
session with me at next and so we asked
him a little bit about his work his path
into data science and how he got to
where he is now which is
director of science at primer a start-up
here in the Bay Area which as a teaser I
mean this interview was wild right I
mean we heard so many cool stories I'm
just remembering all the fun things that
we talked it's a really really good
interview sorry really really really
really really really really good it was
one of my favorites for sure he's just a
fascinating person but before we get to
that we have a really exciting question
of the week that follows up from our
conversation with John we do but even
before we get to the question of the
week we're gonna do our cool thing of
the week cool thing of the week there
are so many this is the week right after
Google i/o we were both there last week
we had so much to do it was an
action-packed week so how do we condense
that into cool things of the week well
I'm glad you asked because as it turns
out all of the sessions that happened at
i/o and actually all the sessions that
happen at next which wasn't that long
ago all of those are available on
YouTube for people to rewatch now
there's a ton of sessions at both and as
you can imagine you know Google cloud
next had a ton of cloud content io had
some cloud content but there was a lot
of other talks there especially focusing
on other Google things like Android and
Chrome and so on so all of those talks
are available on YouTube if you go to
the GCP cloud youtube channel as well as
the links we'll probably put down in the
show notes you can check out all these
different sessions you can kind of read
through them and see what they're about
and see who was talking and kind of
catch up on the topics that you think
we're interesting but I know that you
know while we were there I was hanging
out mostly at the community booth
talking with people looking at some of
the new announcements but you had a
chance to actually go to some session so
what was your favorite session what was
your favorite toad lab and what was your
favorite sandbox oh so many great
questions so if you don't want to go
through all of the videos from i/o if
you just want a shortcut to what was my
favorite session by far that would have
to be the session where Taylor Wilson
interviewed Michio Kaku so he is one of
my favorite scientists i've been reading
his books for years he's been on so many
PBS programs he's a very public facing
scientist and there's not that many of
them out there so he's been
pretty transformational for me and what
I really enjoyed about the session it
was sort of a fireside chat format so
Taylor has a lot in common with him and
you could tell that this scientist in
particular was very formative for
Taylor's early years and so he was just
so excited to be interviewing him and
there was so much energy in the room and
he asked such intelligent questions
there was so much overlap in their
backgrounds it was just really
fascinating to watch it was not only a
fascinating interview but the
interviewer was also just really on
point so I recommend that session it was
by far my favorite so that would
definitely be one of the great videos to
check out on YouTube so what about the
sandbox is I mean there are a lot of
really cool demos out there that people
could actually get hands on and play
around with from again a wide variety of
Google products which ones did you kind
of like the best my favorite would be
the one called AI on the edge this was
created by a few of our co-workers Abe
Weiss Noah no gray and Johann Lou or
both on my team and Gus Luiz Gustavo
Martin's they all put this together and
the cool thing about that is the sand
boxes are physical instantiation of
these projects and so it was like a
living remember on The Price is Right
the Plinko boards oh absolutely
remembers the Plinko boards right the
best game so you have that like round
token that sort of makes its way down
and drops into a slot so the cool thing
about this is that it used tensorflow
light to identify the number that was on
the token and then it would drop it down
into the right slot according to the
number that was written on the token it
was super cool so there were a couple
parts to this there was image
recognition before recognizing the
number and that was I believe that was
an on device edge TPU and then there was
also the object recognition which was an
Android app all of that was using
tensorflow light so different types of
hardware and the models that they used
digit detection was taken from auto ml
and then the object detection was using
mobile net and the cool thing about that
is that all the code that ran that will
be open sourced Gabe is essentially
opening it this week so by the time the
show comes out it should be out and
you'll be able to see all the code that
went into it everything they went behind
it and he is also in the process of
writing a blog post or severals
stay tuned on the GCP blog for a written
description of everything that he put
together so you too can feel like you
were at i/o to view the AI on the edge
sandbox that's the best part about it
right because if you didn't get a chance
to come the sessions are out on YouTube
a lot of the code hopefully not just
Gabe's demo are going open source
there's still a lot of hands-on stuff
that you probably can't replicate which
is why you should probably come to the
next year's i/o but if you weren't able
to make it there are lots and lots of
cool ways to catch up with that not only
that but code labs are another great way
right yeah so that's where I spent most
of my time in the code lab section and
my favorite lab was the one that uses a
spark fun edge board so this one also
uses TF light which is what was powering
Gabe demo so it's a ion a
microcontroller with TF light and I had
seen this a few weeks before by one of
the lead researchers on the project but
at i/o was the first time where users
could come together and they had all the
written instructions than they got to do
this themselves so it walks them through
on the board creating these models
putting it onto the board and then you
could like yell at the board it was a
speech recognizer and then the right
colored light would go off and so you
had throughout the code labs people just
randomly screaming yes yes no something
very similar with animals and people had
to scream out the animal noises which
was an interesting demo as well that was
the highlight of cool apps for me was
that one lab oh that's awesome and you
know one of the other cool things that
was at i/o was the detox zone which I
mean we were just talking about mental
health awareness and how important it is
absolutely so that was probably my
favorite like miscellaneous zone I
really appreciate it there was a place
for people to sort of retreat what I
loved about IO and it was so different
from next it was more of a like
developer festival atmosphere it was all
outdoors and it was much different from
next so Nexus in Moscone Iowa's outdoors
and you were part of nature which I
appreciated in this digital detox zone
was kind of off to the side in a corner
and I think my favorite part about it is
that there was a woman at a booth with a
typewriter offering poems so you could
just walk up and get a poem and she
didn't even use a laptop and it was
literally just a piece of paper that she
handed to you it was it was lovely so in
the middle of this like detox garden it
was a fantastic
contrast to the rest of the sort of
overwhelming festival atmosphere so it's
really great experience you know
obviously for people who do get a chance
it's super super awesome if you don't
you know we do our best to try and get
as much of that experience out there but
they're probably just isn't quite any
way to replicate it other than showing
up that's right so come next year it was
my first i/o and I am definitely going
back next year it was fantastic awesome
to hear well I don't want to delay our
conversation with John any longer so
should we dive into that look it started
[Music]
all right welcome everyone we're very
happy to have our special guest today
John Bohannon here from primer he's the
director of science there hi I'm your
host Michelle Kasbah and I'm a developer
programs engineer here at Google cloud
and co-host mark merchandani
developer advocate here at Google cloud
and we're very excited about today's
episode so John and I we did a session
last week at Google Next and I was
fascinated so meeting John and preparing
for our session I just learned so many
things about him and I had to invite him
onto the show to tell us more because
there are so many rabbit holes and
you've been telling me about this for
this recording so like I'm it's super
exciting for me to kind of understand
and I you know we're talking before the
recording and like I think John does a
lot of cool content to share but before
we get into that John can you tell us
who you are and what you do okay
so I'm John Bohannon and these days I'm
designing artificial intelligence to
essentially read and write so that
humans don't have to that sounds very
exciting is this because humans are lazy
or because maybe the results are better
you know humans work very hard and in
fact the things we're building are most
useful for the humans who work really
hard whose job involves reading and
writing so broadly speaking if your job
is an analyst you could be in government
or banking or corporate or even a
journalist which is something that I've
done in my life it kind of boils down to
the same thing
you spend the first half of your day
reading way more than you could possibly
read the second half writing make sense
of what you read and help someone make a
decision or inform the public or inform
you know decision maker we try and
automate as much as possible of that
stack of tasks so what does that mean
when you say automate something like
reading yeah how do you do that so for
example when I first joined primer when
we were very small I was leading an
effort to build a product called primer
science that reads papers for you and so
it was a really weird situation kind of
like a snake eating its own tail I soon
discovered because I found myself using
this thing in order to more efficiently
find scientific papers that describe the
latest techniques that I needed to build
the thing so I had I was basically
making something that would help me make
it
and we've come a long way like well it's
been a good chat thanks for joining
everybody no I mean that's very it's
very confusing but like the idea that
you're trying to write something to help
power itself is kind of a scary concept
in a lot of ways I think it's actually
less scary so this is not singularity
stuff this is honestly human
augmentation stuff even in a dream
scenario where technologies that augment
humans like go way beyond what we think
is possible currently at the end of the
day this this thing is not aimed towards
becoming a terminated robot it's aimed
at making humans that are much better at
whatever they care about all right so
give us an example of a way that your
system has helped humans how has it made
their jobs easier or made them more
productive yeah so for example we have a
customer who is a health insurance
company one of the biggest in the world
and they have hundreds of medical
policies and there is a team of humans
whose job it is to constantly and I mean
round-the-clock do scientific review to
make sure that those policies are
up-to-date and it's a legal requirement
but also like a functional requirement
if you're gonna have policies that cover
the latest techniques and diseases as we
learn about them someone has to actually
keep up with the science and that is an
impossible task like even for that team
which is a big team who are really good
at this there are on order of at least
10 times too many papers to read at
least so what they do is they take
shortcuts like we all do as humans they
rely on advice from people that read
review papers then hopefully that review
people are kind of covered enough that I
don't have to read all the things that
went into it and also just random
sampling like that I think that is
actually the main technique humans use
when there's too much for them to do is
they just kind of random sample and hope
that they're more or less covering
whatever it is so anyway we have this
system set up to just read all pubmed
papers for them constantly and there are
classifiers that are working in the
background to help them find the things
that are actually relevant to any given
policy they still have to read papers
they still have to make sense of stuff
but they get like a huge compression of
that information so everything is topic
modeled and Bend and summarized and you
know the most impactful papers as
described in the news or even on Twitter
are all being kind of sequenced together
and
impressed okay so so you're saving
people time you're helping them do their
jobs where did you come up with this
idea where did the idea for the system
come from oh I mean originally this was
the first thing built at primer and it
was just a prototype
we know we're onto something with
automating reading and writing if we can
do it on a really hard document type a
scientific paper so it was really just a
prototype it kind of reminds me of like
the college days when I mean like really
I'm sure a lot of the college people
have kind of come up with these
shortcuts naturally because that's how
the human brain works especially where I
don't know about y'all in college but I
was maybe not exactly an exemplary
student but the idea was you know you
had a tremendous amount of resources
that you needed to kind of consume in
order to you know usually turn out a
paper or something like that and so
there are all kinds of you know either
you get the short versions you get these
summaries sounds like that is probably
something that was pretty instilled into
what humans naturally kind of tend to do
especially when you get you know more
and more complex things like scientific
papers yeah and and it's not just the
reading side so we also try and write
the first draft of things for you the
requirement here is not to make it
perfect ready to publish the goal is
like do better than a blank page like
get something together that you can work
with quickly and how was that process
going from blank page to what I assume
the first couple renditions were maybe
not necessarily the most readable of
papers oh well I mean the cool thing is
just over the past two years of building
technology at primer I've covered the
whole arc of approaches so in the
beginning you start with rule-based
systems heuristics you just like write
exactly what will be written with
substitutions like you know if you get
this as data then say it this way insert
thing it's like mad living but it can
get really really complicated and in
fact that's why people ultimately turn
away from these systems is like if you
have a problem that is sufficiently
complex no amount of rule writing is
going to get you there it's just too
brittle you can't capture the complexity
of the world beyond that what you can do
is use extractive techniques so you have
input documents and you have a system
that finds the bits of those documents
that are most relevant to whatever the
need is and then assembles them together
Frankenstein style and you know it
mostly works one thing that's really
nice is you're guaranteed that any given
sentence that the system says will at
least be a reasonable sentence because
it was written by human
what you're not guaranteed is that the
whole thing actually works at that
paragraph or document level and then the
dream is abstractive where you give the
system access to the english language or
even just the english alphanumeric
character system and it goes sequence to
sequence basically things come in it
decides what to say
basically word by word or character by
character and spits out text the problem
with that is it runs off the rails very
quickly and becomes incoherent no one
has solved that problem
in fact people right here at Google have
done some of the most groundbreaking
work in this and still haven't cracked
it so you know the big news that came
out like a month or two ago was that
open a I had made a universal language
model which is sort of that new hotness
in NLP that was capable of generating
totally coherent text you know
paragraphs at a time and it is true that
often not always it can do that but it's
basically just like sleepwalking you
can't tell it what to say it won't say
anything actually useful but it will
spit out like locally coherent text
that's where we are with state of the
art and there's actually another chapter
to this saga that's going to be starting
soon and we're playing a small part in
that we've got a paper coming out in
archive tomorrow which is we are gonna
be introducing a new way to do text
generation that reframes the problem as
what's called question answering so in
that case it's kind of like blurring the
line between the extract of and
abstractive techniques so an extractive
you're only allowed to grab what humans
have said and stick it in front one
after the other in abstractive you just
read and then you grab you know whatever
you want from a dictionary we've blurred
the line between the two by reframing
this as you're asking a question and
then looking into the text as a
dictionary for the answer so the whole
text becomes essentially the vocabulary
on offer which can range from a single
comma you could grab that and say yeah
that's what I want to say or you can
grab an entire sentence and say oh
that's actually it says exactly what I
need to say right now boom and so you
have a more limited
expressivity but we're finding that
actually it's starting to pass the
Turing test with text generation so the
problem that we are publishing about
tomorrow is on headline generation you
can
a headline is like the shortest summary
possible of a document you know a news
headline is essentially trying to tell
you what this article is about but if
you get anything wrong it's totally
useless like you can get away with a
bunch of fudges if you have to generate
like a paragraph long summary it's still
functional you know what the documents
about you change one word X bombs Y
verses y bombs X they have totally
different meanings and of course if you
replace one of those words with the word
wagon then it's also just totally
meaningless so by making the system
concentrate on the vocabulary of the
text we just like happily discovered
that it does amazingly well so humans
vast majority the time can't tell which
headline is actually a machine or human
generated and in the majority of cases
it they judge not knowing which is which
we have them score these headlines and
they more often than not say that the
machine generated headline was as good
or better than the original and by the
way this was all built on Google's birth
so thank you google research for that
nice yeah I hear a lot of positive
things about birth and it's really
fascinating to see how you've made this
progression so I've seen the Quicksilver
code base and it's just fascinating to
see some of those rules that you
generated like they're literal functions
that just generate very specific things
but then that's combined with I can see
how you've progressed as you've been
there and and come up with these new
ideas so I'm really excited to see how
the research that's in your paper how
that's reflected yeah and also I think
everyone's going to start using this
technique now it'll find applications
far beyond what we're using it for by
the time this episode is published we'll
have a link for you and everyone can
read it and what's fascinating is that
it's not your typical sequences sequence
generator it's this totally new way of
looking at the problem reframing it and
it's fascinating and it's made possible
by these big beautiful universal
language models that Google released
that I mean from an AI engineering point
of view is just a dream all the hard
work has been done and you just like pop
off the head and put on a different
thing it's like Lego it's beautiful so
we literally just took a standard
question answer head and stuck it on top
of Bert and then of course we had to do
the training and all that stuff but it
works the other thing I think is
fascinating about that is having seen
your code I was very surprised to learn
that you don't have a classical computer
science background so how did you get
into building something
like Quicksilver long and windy path so
I started off as a molecular biologist
studying the evolution of bacteria and
fun fact I designed a pregnancy test for
cod fish that worked but then my PhD was
on a soil bacterium and trying to
reconstruct essentially Darwinian laws
using experimental evolution and then we
can we go back to the pregnancy test
what was that useful for oh well the
National Marine Fisheries Service needs
to survey the cod population and at the
time what you had to do was pull up net
loads of fish cut them open and weigh
organs and see if the females were
gravid I'm having lots of eggs and not
only is it really inefficient as a
sampling technique but of course you you
can't throw the fish back after you cut
him open and so that among other reasons
was motivation to get a more
sophisticated approach to population
surveys so you saved Cod live I did I am
responsible for some number of Cod lives
excellent okay continue and so then I
wanted to do something different instead
of diving into the next lab job for my
postdoc and so I sent a letter to the
editor of science saying I hear that you
might have some kind of interesting
opportunities for someone like me I'm a
molecular biologist and a playwright who
has saved all these Cod no I didn't even
bring that up I think it was literally
as weird as I'm a molecular biologist
playwright because well the playwright
stuff you haven't even talked about well
during my PhD I was like spending like
way too much of my time doing
extracurriculars among which was like a
lot of like stage writing and acting and
what I later found out was that my
letter circulated as a joke at science
well I mean it's good to be known for
something well that's the beauty of this
approach so and that was one of n spores
that I send out on the winds trying to
find out what my next life chapter
should be and so when I got a response I
was kind of surprised and forgotten it
mostly that I had even sent that one and
I got a response from the news editor of
science who in a former life was a
novelist he's now at the New York
Academy of Sciences and he said well you
know you have an interesting background
I think we have a news internship would
that be a fit and I was in England and
doing my PhD and not far away at
Cambridge they had just set up the first
international office for science
the news editor there was just setting
up shop and kind of wanted to have a
news intern but no one knew about it and
so I just like snuck in not a single
like piece of writing to my name what
what year was that 2000 to 2002 I was
not a Cambridge yet so he started out as
a news intern in Cambridge in England
yeah with a PhD yes and within like a
couple months of doing that I found
myself in an obscure city in China
investigating a body factory where human
cadavers are turned into artwork
[Music]
[Applause]
where my yes where my mission was to get
proof if it existed that this body
factory was sourcing its human cadavers
from the Chinese government it is the
number one executors of prisoners in the
world so that seems like a great source
of bodies and I got confirmation they
were getting bodies from the Chinese
state Wow so when I had that experience
I basically never looked back I was like
oh this is what I'm supposed to be doing
and I then did that for more than a
decade and you investigated many more
exciting topics yes what was your
favorite topic that you ever covered it
depends on the flavor of favor okay that
depends on what you mean by favorite
what was the most interesting story you
wrote about so interesting to the
audience was probably some of the
weirder stories that I've done like I
organized and ran the first scientific
conference within a virtual game world
World of Warcraft with the director of
human centered computing at the NSF no
question is what level was he 70 which
at the time was of course that was the
max set I don't know if it still is now
don't either but I mean like that
actually is no not incredibly uncommon
right they've started to have a lot of
event led meetups inside of virtual
worlds whether that is yep you know
popular video games or whether they have
had all this this fortnight stuff and
all those I mean it's been tremendously
interesting to see the intersection
between real life and where people want
to bring their interests into that even
though they're not related to the game
so maybe you kind of pioneered a little
bit of that effort yeah I think I was
part of that that first wave and it does
make things possible that are just not
practical in the real world for example
like for entertainment during this big
scientific conference we went out on a
raid and absolutely everyone got killed
I you know in horrible ways and then we
got to laugh about it over virtual beers
the most amazing thing given it's pretty
great that's awesome
but yeah I think interesting to me was
embedding with NATO forces in Kandahar
during the surge in Afghanistan and I
was there to try and convince the
military to release a data set they
didn't realize it but that was my actual
secret mission and I succeeded and so I
engineered the first ever honest public
release of civilian casualty data from
the
Nations and NATO forces and I say honest
because they actually used to do that
routinely during the Vietnam War the US
military would actually publish casualty
numbers in the newspaper this was during
the period of the war of attrition the
idea being that if we were killing ten
communists for every one US soldier we
were winning and so it was actually my
stats professor when he was a grad
student
he started analyzing those numbers and
proved that they were being cooked
because the distribution of the final
digit was not following a random
distribution at all can you guess which
numbers were abnormally infrequent
infrequent zero you got it if you're
gonna publish fake numbers you better
make it feel real by saying that 27
communists were killed so if you have
one takeaway from this episode to make
sure you correctly falsify numbers by
using an actual rate of distribution
exactly if you're gonna cook the books
do it right so how are you able to
convince them to release this honest
data so first of all is just like a lot
of face time with officers in Kandahar
and visiting hospitals and just sort of
being there with the teams so and you
were there as press as a journalist and
so I learned a lot about the US military
well NATO as well but like I was mostly
around a lot of US military officers but
I really did not realize until I spent a
lot of time with him how much it is like
a face to face culture it's such a vast
and inefficient bureaucracy that think
that everything is just sort of we even
have a term for all that was done with
military precision and that does mean
something but actually how things move
in such a huge organization is not
precise it's very efficient and
basically when things get done it's
because people are really invested in it
and they make it happen and so I feel
like a lot of what I did in Afghanistan
was just convincing the right people
that this is the kind of thing you
should do like this this data is not
going to do any harm to release it will
do a lot of good and so I basically
asked for a little bit and I got a
little bit and I was like ah this is
really you know no one's ever seen this
and this really helps make the case that
you were describing about how for
example this new approach to roadblocks
has started to reduce civilian
casualties you know if you gave me a
little bit more data I could probably
show that you know has made a difference
in regions where you've stood up that
new technique and released a little bit
more it's like oh well that's really
interesting you know what else
you know this other thing that you
really care about if you've got the data
to show it and slowly but surely like I
had everything but some patches and I
was like well why not just release the
whole thing and it just became a lot
easier but there's no way I could have
done that from a distance yes no way at
all and what did you do with that data
set once you release it once you have
published it and Science released it
publicly
what did other people do with that data
set you know a lot of analysis a lot of
advocating there was a more than twofold
gap in the number of casualties reported
by the military compared to the UN
observers and we could see that for the
first time and you know that had to be
accounted for so it just basically
turned on the discourse everyone
suddenly had something to talk about I
think it just like planted a flag in
history that if you were going to be a
huge occupying force for better or worse
you better like be transparent but we
now have conflicts like in Syria where
there's no one essentially to hold
accountable so it's not a fix for our
bigger problems but it was important at
the time ok so at this point you're
journalists you've been traveling around
the world following these really
exciting stories so how do you get from
that kind of lifestyle
to AI python python of course of his
python snake know the out good call back
pretty good no the the coding language I
had a project involving the Google
engrams data set so the team at Harvard
that built the data set and as well as
the Ngram viewer which is alive and well
today and really cool it grew out of the
Google Books project those two people
grad students at Harvard were just
friends of mine I was basically like
moonlighting as a researcher in that
group and so when that paper came out on
the cover of science along with it was a
story that I did about the history of
science as seen through the lens of that
data set and it was a really frustrating
experience for me because I was beholden
to this undergrad at Harvard who had to
do the very basic data manipulations for
me because the data sets were far too
large to deal with in spreadsheets and I
didn't know how to code yet and you know
I knew exactly what I wanted to do like
I could write it down like do this but I
couldn't express it in code and so the
day after that got published I was like
enough is enough I've got to learn how
to solve these problems for myself and
well I got obsessed once you have a
hammer everything looks like a coding
problem so I don't know what you're
talking about using Python to solve
every single problem you encounter
no one in this room has ever done that
before that wouldn't be a realistic
scenario so it got obsessed about coding
and then slowly but surely I went from
being a like foreign correspondent who
runs around to places like China and
Afghanistan to find stories to someone
who tries to get datasets and pull out
stories worth telling from data and then
it became like building things that read
data and then it became like wow maybe I
could actually contribute to open source
coding and share some of these solutions
and then I moved to the Bay Area to do a
visiting postdoc thing at Berkeley in
their new data Science Institute and my
friend Sean Gourley just across the
water in San Francisco had a new startup
called primer and he tried this trick on
me before when he had a startup before
this it's like just come come over and
we have really cool resources and data
you you should just come play and now
that I lived in the same city I was like
all right all right right and after like
one day at primer that we don't really
ten people's is he think room with a
bunch of empty desks and I was sitting
there working on the problem at the time
which was I wanted to make a quote
extractor so this was 2015 and I wanted
to get all the quotes of Donald Trump my
journalist colleagues were chasing their
own tails trying to like catch him
contradicting himself and you know any
of his copious publicly quoted
statements and I was surprised to learn
there is no database of quotes from him
nor is there a database of quotes from
anyone and so I started looking into it
and got on github found that someone who
made a good first attempt at a quote
extractor and then the project kind of
petered out and I actually tracked down
that person and I was like you know what
happened to this I'd love to take this
further you know why did why'd you stop
and he was like cuz it's hard and I need
to get paid or something what about it
makes it hard so you'd think that you
could just make a regular expression
that would find anything between
quotation marks but famous last words
well you're also gonna capture anything
that's in quotation marks like scare
quotes here's the review of the movie
Titanic where Titanic's in quotes
now you've essentially got a huge source
of junk in things are supposed to be
quotes then you've got an even harder
problem let's say you did have clean
quotes you've just got the perfect data
set of truly quoted human statements how
do you figure out who said it so that's
the problem of attribution so you could
imagine making regular expression that
will capture human names downstream you
know
so and so or so and so says and you know
you might be able to capture those spans
but it's a lot trickier than you think
people basically have a near infinite
way of expressing that someone said
something and attributing it to them and
that hadn't even touched like the
he-said she-said like now you have a
problem that's a really classic hard
problem in NLP called entity coreference
resolution we're given a text that
mentions multiple people that uses an
afro like he and she him and her his and
hers you have to figure out who like
corresponds which entity actually
corresponds to what bit of text now
you're in like uncharted territory so
it's just really hard so day one at
primer I sat next to this crazy
Ukrainian named Leonard that Michelle
has met he's absolute dear and hilarious
and wonderful yeah he's really great and
very skilled at NLP yes he is as we call
it a mensch worth mentioning yes and on
day one what are you working on and I
and I I was like digging into his quote
stuff and he's like oh yeah we already
solved that you know the harder problem
is this one and he likes insurance show
me what he was working on and by the end
of the day I was like okay I'll join
okay fine I could probably spend the
next six months of my life doing unpaid
work to try and fix quote extraction for
everyone else or I could join a start-up
that's like trying to pull all that
together into true automated reading and
writing and I mean how can you say no to
Leonard he's a dear he is wonderful okay
so your common thread up to this point
has been interesting problems to solve
data and finding sort of new ways of
doing things that other people haven't
seen before haven't applied to those
types of problems yeah okay so how does
dance tie in to your interest in AI oh
yeah that's a weird cold a sac in my
life well you were already a playwright
like you're already used to being on
stage so okay I was living in Vienna
Austria as a foreign correspondent in
2006 and 7 when I had this party that I
was helping organize it was a New Year's
Eve party that didn't actually happen on
New Year's Eve but whatever it was round
about New Year's Eve and I wanted it to
be a dance party like I just always feel
disappointed at a nice big party when no
dancing occurs I just feel like it's a
crime against humanity and that's too
strong
we've heard about some different stories
today like the dance party it's hard to
get people to dance in general and it's
actually surprisingly hard to get a
group of frustrated scientist grad
students to dance mmm I don't know why
that is it's just like it's a pretty
tough crowd - I know that is yeah but is
it is it nature and nurture are people
who don't want to dance becoming grad
students or is there something about the
grad life experience that makes you not
want to dance unsolved problems so sure
there's a machine-learning over for all
you listening at home if you've got an
idea about this posted on twitter at
hashtag reasons for dance so the reasons
for dance move so I proposed a contest a
dance contest to motivate like the
audience that we're all scientists
question so I was like you have to dance
your PhD so in a short dance you must
express the basic idea the essence of
your PhD but with no words no jargon no
PowerPoint slides you have to just dance
it which honestly to me sounds harder
than doing a PhD well there are some
people that feel the opposite and this
contest is basically it's become a huge
filter in the world to find that
population we almost do we being me and
science the journal who hosts this
contest every year for 11 years and
running we do minimal marketing really
like it's just like a post on Facebook
and we put out a little story online
people just come out of the woodwork
from all over the world from countries
all over the world and take part but the
reason it turned into a contest at all
was because after that party so long ago
in Vienna we shot some good video of the
actual contest the dances and put it
online and I wrote a story for science
about it just for fun and then the email
started coming in from scientists just
all over the world saying I'm ready
you know when Wednesday people were
excited when this next year's contest
kick off and you filled a gap there was
a need there was a new plans no plans
for this but then I was like I guess we
do have to do it and because people were
asking from all over the world like I
had no money for this can't do a live
event so I was like oh well we could do
it as an online video contest and
YouTube had roundabouts 2007-8 it was
like working pretty well
I was like okay put your dances on
YouTube send me the link and I'll
assemble a judge of experts like I did
the first time around from the worlds of
science and dance and they'll you know
they'll determine the winners and the
prize when we started was a one-year
subscription to science that's perfect
and it hasn't gotten much grander than
that it's like you get a thousand bucks
is as fancy as we've gotten well I think
it's because people aren't doing it for
the prize they're doing it for the
passion of it yeah exactly
they would have been doing this anyway
they're probably already were doing it
in the shower and they just needed the
audience that's what this provides okay
so you have all of a sudden you have all
these people around the world
describing scientific topics through
dance yeah oh by the way this past
year's winner was a PhD student in
Canada who studies quantum properties of
materials and he not only organized this
awesome dance video but he wrote and
performed a song for that video it's
like so over the top I mean if you're
gonna go any portion of the way you may
as well go all the way and get your own
original composition yeah okay so people
are describing scientific topics do
dance of course that's a natural leap
through like applying AI to that how do
you mean exactly so I'm trying to make a
connection between a workshop I went to
there was this like AI and dance
workshop there's this group here in San
Francisco that meets weekly yes and it's
amazing I was baffled at how AI and
dance came together and so I'm curious
to hear what the bridge was for you how
did you get from dancer PhD to AI and
dance so yeah that thing that happens
every Wednesday is called kinetic Arts
and by the way it's a public event so
all you Bay Area people who are
listening you are very welcome to join
you can find it on meetup.com and it's
essentially like a bunch of
technologists who get together with a
bunch of mostly dancers but art people
and we do experiments together so
we'll wire up dancers with motion
capture suits and then run an experiment
where we generate music based on their
movement for example one time we we
brought in the research group from
Berkeley who had that paper route last
year in which you learn how to dance on
a human skeleton model by having the
system just like watch video of someone
dancing and then apply that movement to
a model of someone else's body so if you
Michelle like were to take part what
would happen is you would just be
walking around manipulating your limbs
for a while in a pretty random way so
that it gets sort of all the angles of
you and makes a model if your skeleton
and then it can apply any dance that's
ever learned to you and generate a video
of you doing that dance so I mean you
can make videos of people dancing ballet
at the level of the Bolshoi you know
breakdancing the important part is
that's not deeply terrified because now
we're kind of getting into that what is
it from the past couple of months laughs
deep fake yeah that's right this idea
that you can now basically say oh video
footage is no longer reliable yeah
because it's too easy to simulate the
master level that we have now you've got
all these intense AI and no properties
that are putting put together to say you
know anyone can be caught doing anything
or saying anything because we have all
the technology required to simulate it
yep and while you know like applying
dance movement to someone's body like
it's hard to imagine how that could go
terribly wrong it's it's only like a few
steps away from a lot of terrible things
yeah I wish I could say that like we
have enough time to carefully think
through and make policies around this
but it's already here and we don't have
those policies and and even then without
those policies I mean people are going
to play around with it right I mean this
whole community is driven on the I mean
open source in general people are like
encouraged to experiment and play around
with absolutely you naturally get people
who are like oh I wonder if I can do
this and then they do yeah and then
they're like hey I'm gonna go talk to my
friends about this and then you kind of
just build this entire boulder that's
kind of rolling down a hill of like wow
these are things that are completely
unchecked and there's a lot of kind of
scary practices I mean I know we're
being really vague about what those deep
but I think people can use their
imaginations there's a lot of really
scary stuff out there I don't even know
how you would kind of put organization
around it yeah I mean that's a whole
policy discussion but essentially the
best idea I've heard is that you need to
have laws on the books that make real
consequences for hurting people by
reputation or however it has a negative
impact you have to have laws on the
books that have consequences and what I
really liked about that group is they
weren't just sort of getting together in
a room experimenting like we started out
the workshop with the discussion and
they asked some really intriguing
questions it was it was people who maybe
don't understand the technology very
well trying to understand it more and
asking important questions that people
who use technology haven't thought of it
was that coming together of those two
domains that I found just fascinating
that that there was so much crossover in
interests and like what can we achieve
like that's where innovation has
happened traditionally is when you get
these two intersecting fields that come
together and like oh we haven't looked
at this problem from that perspective
before yep and it's what I love about
the event especially is that it's not
just one-sided it's not just like naive
people from outside of science ask you
know hard questions that inspire
scientists to better explain and think
about their own stuff it also goes the
other way so we had one night not too
long ago where we were playing with a
new piece of technology that senses your
heartbeat and transmits it via a router
to whatever you want it to go to and so
we sent it to essentially the sound
system of the room very straightforward
so you you basically strap this thing on
to someone and suddenly the entire room
is engulfed in their heartbeat and so as
they become calm or excited essentially
like everyone experiences it so it's
kind of like very simple concept well
executed and then we then just like
switched over to dance mode where like
we have some of the most amazing people
from the dance community in San
Francisco just there helping to run this
thing and they know how to take a room
of people even non movers people who
aren't used to being movers and make it
safe for them to start moving suddenly
the entire room was basically this
spontaneous dance event and it was
really beautiful and people just came up
to me afterwards like who have never
experienced they were like you know
that's amazing is this like every
Wednesday and yeah it's that easy you
just get people in the room with good
intentions and you do some really cool
stuff yeah it's fascinating I love that
there are so many aspects to your
journey that you're not just someone
who's working on AI now but you're a
person with these very rich experiences
it's very rich background is there
anything else you'd like to share about
your background well we've got a really
big history all the cool things and I
know that you know we've probably gone a
little long would definitely be useful
to ask like is there any where you're
going here soon or there anywhere you're
gonna be are there any cool dance
competitions coming up I think I should
find you at well let's see the big thing
in my life right now is that the archive
paper that we've been working on for a
while is coming out tomorrow and let's
see beyond that I did want to ask you
what your favorite job was oh
I mean was it the saving the fish was it
you know working with the military and
getting the numbers was it being it Jack
I mean there's a lot of jobs you've had
clearly I I think there's a special
place in my heart still for the year
after graduating from undergrad before
grad school where I was a nude model for
art classes at Amherst Smith and Mount
Holyoke simply because it was pretty
well-paying at the time for me and they
didn't have enough males and I did it
just for like life experience but
actually now that I've done yoga I
actually know what I was tapping into
but it was like my first experience with
meditation and in a very unusual setting
and I got paid to meditate basically so
you were meditating while people painted
you the best time in that period was
working for one sculptor so I had to
hold the same pose for week after week
after week and so it just whittles away
your awareness of your body at the same
time it hyper concentrates your
awareness the body is very hard to
explain but I really have a very
sentimental recollection of that child
of all the lessons I expected to hear
from someone who has experience as a
nude model that was probably the last
one I expected to hear and I think it's
amazing what did you expect to hear I'll
cut it off right there I'm not sure
where that's going to go there but you
know
talking to some people you know some
people have they've kind of said like
look it's in some ways it's boring right
they're kind of sitting around they're
like you got to do something to occupy
your mind because you have to hold still
so actually I think that kind of concept
of like yeah you kind of end up
meditating mmm is a really poignant one
but also probably a really real one for
a lot of those people out there yeah I
can't move for 45 minutes what I'm gonna
do yeah and I discovered it accidentally
beautiful part it's an important life
skill that serves you well today I'm
sure I wish I was better at it but yeah
with the modeling yeah I think we're
just about at a time all right thank you
John it was awesome having you here I
appreciate you taking us through that
journey of your history experience and
for all you listening nice to meet you
thank you so much done and now what
we've all been waiting for the question
of the week
well so we had a really really awesome
conversation with John so I get a
feeling it might be tied to that so the
big question that everyone's wanting to
know how can we be like John oh that's a
very tall order for everyone who just
listened it was a great conversation we
learned a lot about how John took a
really unique path I think through life
and did a lot of very very cool things
but on top of that is also now kind of
currently building out really complex
models and I think we've had a kind of a
recurring theme in the past couple of
episodes I mean ever we do talk about
machine learning and saying like hey
it's a really high barrier so how do we
be more like John but really in this
case is how do we kind of get started
with machine learning or build out some
of the stuff he's learning without the
many many years of experience and kind
of life challenges that he worked
through well in this case we've actually
just pushed out a great blog post which
is also a code lab that really looks at
a walkthrough of how to build an auto ml
natural language classifier and the
beautiful part about Auto ml if you're
not familiar with it is it lets you
build machine learning models without
really writing any code right so you
kind of send the data you classify what
that data looks like and then it trains
a machine learning model for you that in
itself is magic but this walks through
like how do you actually put the magic
in your hands how do you build that out
how do you go from here's a set of data
to here's a working machine learning
prediction model and actually a pretty
short period of time I walk through it
and I was shocked at how quick you could
kind of just build this entire thing out
I think it's always surprising to see
all the machine learning in actions and
you know I don't know a lot about
machine learning so it's fascinating to
see how easy it is to dive in there yeah
Auto ml in particular it's really
interesting the way they've built this
service so it uses something called
transfer learning so the service trains
a bunch of models behind the scenes and
then you come in with your data and it
sort of adds your specific use case on
top of the models that have already been
built and it gives you a much more
personalized model but it's still very
accurate because of how they built it
and it's a great way to get started if
you don't really know much about deep
learning because it's a UI and you don't
need a whole lot of data and you can
leverage a lot of the hard work by
people who know a lot more about deep
learning than I do which is absolutely
the bucket that I fall in so I am more
than happy to take advantage
the kind of the cool resources that have
been built and this guide that people
can kind of again just go right now and
step through so we'll make sure to have
a link to that in the show notes
excellent okay great so before we wrap
up where are we all gonna be anything
cool coming up yeah so I'm headed out in
a few days
I'll be heading to Barcelona for kube
Connie I'll be there for a few weeks so
I'm giving a workshop on cube flow if
you want an introduction to cute little
pipelines my workshop is a place to be
there will be a video of it if you're
not physically in Barcelona for the
event it's a publicly available code lab
and there will be videos you can follow
along so if you're not there you won't
have to miss out we'll add it to a
future show nuts I think the idea I mean
this is a big convention for for Cuban
Indies in general right and I think that
a lot of people who can't make it out
there similar to IO and next right the
best efforts go into try and making this
content consumable but sometimes it can
be hard to replicate that conference
experience where you headed this week
well as per usual I'm gonna bunker down
and stay here in the Bay Area you know I
think we spend a lot of energy going
around next in i/o but I don't tend to
travel that often which is you know also
a big part of my mental health awareness
because I'm sure that that might be
challenging if I traveled as much as
everyone else did speaking of which mark
is over in Japan right he is he's in
Japan this week and Gabby is in France
so we have a lot of traveling going on I
mean for people who already you know
kind of are based here in the States
these are some far distances to go so I
would definitely be exhausted I know
John's out on the East Coast here in New
York and then Brian's traveling over to
I think Colorado soon I believe so so
there's a lot of events going on I think
you know some people are still
recovering from IO and kind of taking
that time back and saying okay let's put
a pause and some of the conferencing and
see where maybe hopefully some personal
travel or maybe some quieter times lay
I'm definitely looking forward to being
in Europe this week
I lived there a few years ago I lived in
Germany and I haven't been back in a
decade and so I'm really looking forward
to connecting with some old friends and
having a little bit of personal travel
in between a few work-related things I
think it's the right way to do it yeah
oh one other really exciting part of my
Europe trip guess where I get to go more
than Barcelona and Germany I have no
idea so this is something I've been
wanting to do for almost my entire life
but I finally finally finally get to go
take a tour of CERN that's right so I
get to
the everything that michio kaku was
talking about in his session i get to
see much of it in person atom smashers
particle accelerators all kinds of
things I'm so excited in person for the
first time I mean this is a dream come
true for you it sounds like and probably
for a lot of other people it is
fantastic and I have a few friends
coming along with me so we all get to
experience it together it will be
magical well then we will definitely
have you come back on afterwards and
talk a little bit about how it was and
all the cool super-secret science stuff
that none of us have access to I'll tell
you all about it very excited all right
well perfect thanks everyone for
checking in and we'll see you all next
week
all right see you then
[Music]